pop
[Applaudissements]
de quoi
terrain des machines
m
strasbourg colmar colmar strasbourg
cette fois par jour le tgv train à
grande vitesse parcours la plaine
d'alsace pour des essais techniques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'opérateur et sel
karine laurent emmanuel et estelle en
ont profité pour monter à bord de ce
train futuriste
[Applaudissements]
je te parler
franchement les radios
[Applaudissements]
mais normalement averti
les ingénieurs et techniciens qui ont
conçu et construit le tgv ont dessiné
ces lignes aérodynamiques
ils ont inventé une signalisation
spéciale et améliorer la sécurité le
confort des voyageurs et des conducteurs
[Applaudissements]
et parce que les tgv apportera-t-il aux
villes pays bas sera ben il apportera un
gain de temps énorme par rapport au
train actuel puisque pour aller à lyon
par exemple on mettra plus de deux
heures au lieu de presque 4 heures
maintenant c'est déjà pas mal
il apportera surtout la vitesse
les démolitions absolument pas on va
rouler sur des voies qui sont au niveau
identique à celles sur lesquelles nous
roulent enchaînements en tout point
identique se sont pas des rails spéciaux
d'ailleurs les rames tgv
elles ne vont pas rouler que sur la
nouvelle ligne elles vont aussi aller
sur les lignes actuelles au delà de lyon
vers marseille vers montpellier vers
grenoble
mais ces nouvelles lignes et ce qu'elle
n'était pas certain dans vos villages
on a pris des précautions énorme pour ne
pas défaillir pour ne pas pour bien
s'inscrire dans le paysage il faut ne
pas dégrader rôle bryza
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour rouler à 260 km/heure le tgv a
besoin d'une voie ferrée qui épouse au
plus près le relief naturel la ligne
spéciale qui est construite sera la
plupart du temps une ligne droite
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[ __ ] on par exemple
la donne et higuain
avec un trail comme ça on ne s'arrêtera
pas un lifting il y a deux gardes prévu
en tout cas du lion et encore il ya très
peu de prix qui s'y arrêter
alors maintenant tu parles de prévoir un
système pour des cent des voyageurs en
marche au fonds actuel est parachuté on
n'a pas encore inventé
jamais
oui les accrocher en marche des projets
en marche oui bien sûr ça peut
s'imaginer très bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
quelle image une sortie toit d'un
magasin de loi
[Musique]
que dis tu coupes études et d'ayew
couler c'est moi et louise veine des
plein jour est toute la voie ferrée
chicala c'est une liste va pouvoir
m'aider à retrouver mon tgv attendue
atteint s'annonce c'est un public tu
cherches au cg locales à une ancêtre
mais elle est tout piller les toute
vapeur ce matin qu'elle chute
salut mes belles jeunes filles c'est à
vous ce machin qui m'encombre la voix
ce machin c'est une voiture tgv mais je
voudrais bien savoir où est passée ma
locaux étaient rapides sont elles aussi
perdu ton fait pour je loue que l'inde
mais craint par la vitesse tu sais elle
est capable de battre des records le
flatter ma chère je n'ai plus 20 ans
mais j'ai encore de l'énergie dans les
rouges votre train n'aura pas le dernier
mot pour le doublé elle va le rattraper
au tgv
laisse tomber change de voie vous pouvez
embarquer mais bel ali montée c'est du
solide
vous me voyez fixie celui tombé j'ai vu
ces zones et audi qui est bout je veux
qu'il a une très belle ligne malgré ses
airs accroché pour mme ebelle on va le
rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
encore bravo 0,40 salut et merci dany
beau voyage vitesse je m'en mords moi je
prends ma retraite
[Musique]
rinne
réveille-toi karine on est dans le tgv à
jefara formidable 1
[Musique]
alors vous êtes ici maintenant à belfort
la société alstom où est fabriquée
le tgv
les motrices sont fabriqués entièrement
et elles vont toutes sortes y envoyer de
cet atelier en voilà une qui est prête à
sortir
équivalait aux essais où elle va être à
ce moment là assemblée avait clairement
pour former la rame tgv
[Musique]
j'ai déjà vu ça dans le tgv
ça c'est un anneau d'inter circulation
c'est ce qui permet d'aller d'une
voiture dans une autre
parce que la particularité sur le tgv
c'est que il ya un seul bougies pour 2
rebonds
là on peut aller donc directement d'une
voiture dans une
en passant au travers
d'ailleurs on peut voir ici la partie
qui bouge
et permet ainsi le livre circulation
entre les
[Musique]
quand il sera mis en circulation pas
avant 1983 le tgv sera le plus rapide
des trains du mot et grâce à lui
paris ne sera plus qu'un deux heures de
lyon et inversement
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
la vision que le conducteur les
applications qui sont directement
reportée sur
chercher
et à
mais si lyon
cette capacité
à chaque passage signal
je préfère avaler
sur les classes choc
[Musique]
capter l'attention
et quand il accélère
ainsi vincent à 160
quand on est là patatras
pas les tractations
m
c'est
conakry avant non
paris marseille
penser
[Musique]
pour karine estelle et laurent inutile
d'attendre 1983 pour imaginer nos futurs
voyages en tgv
mais cela ne les empêche pas de rêver
encore et de se documenter sur les
trains comme eux vous pouvez consulter
deux livres passionnants chez hachette
super machine et aux éditions rouge et
or de philippe laurin gros plan sur le
train
[Musique]